you can't go to trevor slattery in iron
man 3 and say
no he actually really was the mandarin
you know but you can still do that with
him
if they want to wreck on it
it has begun hashtag
save quicksilver campaign has started
trending spoilers for wanda vision right
here episode five
evan peter shows up as pietro
quicksilver
all of us fans at least 99.999 percent
of us
were like this must be the introduction
of the multiverse
taking evan peters quicksilver moving
him over here
even the english for the hearing
impaired says
x-men's quicksilver enters that's what
they said
come to find out he's just some guy
named ralph boner
some people are like wait wait wait stu
could be people are
really trying to protect their own
emotions right now which i totally get
trying to justify that maybe that really
is still a quick silver
maybe that ralph boner guy is the
witness protection guy
a lot that has been really deep dived
into
of how none of that adds up director
matt
shakman has come out and he's talked
about how
yeah you know it was just a joke it
pretty much just confirms it
and he does go want to say though like
guys don't worry mutants are
coming you know there's a movie coming
out called multiverse of madness which i
think is like a really big indicator
that
the mutants were announced at comic-con
there's a lot of speculation that since
falcon and winter soldier was actually
supposed to come out originally before
one division
they might start alluding to or
introducing the concept of mutants
in there which would have made it easier
to register this evan peters thing as a
joke
that's just speculation bottom line
hashtag
save quicksilver we don't have a
quicksilver
right now we've got ralph boner and a
dead body and there's one
picture that did come out here that uh i
thought was great for the hashtag save
quicksilver campaign i think it's the
main one
favorite moment from days of future past
it is quicksilver
very much age of ultron didn't see
that's coming actually for me it's the
picking up the hammer but oh yeah i
didn't see that coming school
favorite moment from x-men apocalypse
yes the quicksilver mansion savings
scenes
paper mode from one division easily the
most talked about moment
was when quicksilver showed up favorite
pietro
peterline didn't see that coming
wholesome picks songs that make you
think
of sweet dreams hopes for the future and
hashtag
save quicksilver appreciation yes it is
kind of funny
how quicksilver was the best part of the
x-men movies as of late
you know one of the best parts of them
well the reliably quality sequences you
could count on
yeah i know not everyone's gonna jump on
that train i think
a lot of people though will say like oh
every time he had his moment
it was a standout especially in days of
future past and apocalypse was like one
of the few good things about that one
right and he doesn't get a full
resolution on the ark that they set up
with him as he becomes more
of a character in apocalypse he doesn't
really get that arc some of us were
thinking that maybe now that he's in the
mcu
we might get that obviously did not
occur so
right now what we have is a dead
quicksilver pietro died in age of ultron
so that leaves us in this
area of yeah are we just not going to
get a quicksilver now
are they just waiting for speed to grow
up for young avengers and they'll be
like that's your quicksilver replacement
in the meantime
but quicksilver himself is just a very
specific character and i didn't actually
know about this campaign until today
so to read up on it it really did hit me
like oh damn
we're at risk right now of never having
a quicksilver
so that's just a bummer situation so
yeah
marvel fix this
listen to the fan cave to our demands
and bring them both back you could do
anything now i mean
that's the thing is i got to imagine a
quicksilver will show back up again and
i'm sure
they will have the sense to see this and
to take it into account at the very
least
i don't know what to think i still think
that there could be a kernel of
something to bringing him
over but as of right now yeah i can
definitely understand why people are
upset especially because as
of right now without any other x-men
related news
or content in the shows yet out yeah a
lot of people got to feel like
especially the quick silver
faithful fans got to feel like damn our
boys getting the short end of the stick
kind of every time except for those dead
fox x-men movies now
and i get how fans find that there's
like a a disrespect to the character
he shows up in age of ultron he dies in
his the first movie he shows up in
and i thought like all right well that's
fine at least we got a quick silver in
the x-men universe but in that x-men
universe because of the disney fox deal
we never got to have a resolution on
that character he shows up here
we all get excited and then he's just a
boner joke in the end
i just when you like look at it in the
context of that
like at first it was cool of oh we're
honoring this
we're honoring evan peters and how great
he is like there are some people who
jump on the defensive like
it's a one division show we're not it's
not about quicksilver but i'm like well
she's important to him she's important
to him and
marvel they led with wanting us to
believe
that is the x-men quicksilver so this
does feel like a spin in the face when i
was on the website geekocity
uh yesterday there was a report coming
out that evan peters is actually
supposed to
show up in doctor strange multiverse of
madness supposedly
so maybe this isn't the end you know i'm
under the impression ralph boner
is a guy who was taking over in west
view he had a bill
you know it's been there for months and
the guy with a head shot wouldn't be
someone who's in witness protection
program right i don't know any actor
that would
that's in witness protection
literally against the woman you can't go
public witness protections you can't
have a public
job yeah so i i don't think that's it
like you see that even in the
in the episode one division has pretty
quick speed and agatha has multiple
powers too so i can see how she
like put something in ralph to imbue him
with some super speed right
to give the illusion so i feel like a
lot of this whole thing of him really
being quicksilver's debunked but i feel
like
it was so short-lived in the final
episode in the final episode it was so
brief surprisingly that i feel like they
left them some room to go back
on this or fix it because because it
just ends with oh my god
i forget what the hell ralph boner says
yeah so just look like he was under a
spell and he was just some dude named
ralph boner wasn't quicksilver so i
think that there's a
version where they can go back and be
like no it really was a quicksilver they
could do
it they left them room to change it like
maybe
you can't do that with trevor slattery i
do feel like marvel has
shown an ability in the past to take
things that were thrown out there before
and recontextualize them
or perhaps this is some kind of long
game like with all these theories that
have come up and stuff like that i feel
like there's an element of long game and
while i can see this
being the meme because marvel does at
this point have
this is like a three-fer at this point
with uh you know nick fury's eye
and the mandarin and all that stuff i i
wonder if they
might have approached this with a
certain level of awareness and are going
to surprise us down the line
or if they're just going to pay close
attention to this and then figure out a
way to surprise us later yeah i think
it'd be kind of weird if we got a
third quicksilver even though this is a
disguise
quicksilver we were all for weeks very
much emotionally invested this i think
it'd be weird just got a third guy
it's like you either bring back aaron
taylor johnson in some way another
resurrection
or you've wrecked on the ending of one
division where you add a little bit
more info to be like oh okay she swiped
him over from the other universe but
then she made him think he was just a
normal guy but then made that normal guy
think he was quicksilver
your parents were nobodies they chose to
be yeah i didn't do that
convoluted all right guys well hashtag
save quicksilver
do you agree with this campaign i do
leave your thoughts down below
subscribe click that notification bell
hit that like button
uh last but not least
michael linden what's funny about this
whole one division discussion
is that michael linden is actually
someone
who thought the finale was perfect i
quote
they finished one division perfectly
so i guess you had no problem with the
ralph boner joke i guess people in
sweden
have a better sense of humor about this
than us
egotistical demanding privileged
americans
you love a good boner joke don't you
you're just better than the rest of us
more sophisticated i said you're trying
to insult us you know you didn't say
anything about us directly you just said
that you really love the finale
i think you're saying that we are um
overly critical
and judgmental [ __ ] i'm taking this
which i cannot believe you would say
that about me
so mikhail hope you enjoy your ralphie
ralph jokes
and have a good time in switzerland
oh no oh i got a wrong
country now i'm glad you loved it man
one day you'll get that bond movie
you'll be happy thanks for being here so
good when it gets